This video is sponsored by blue apron a
wise crack.
Jared here today we're talking about the
show that launched a thousand Halloween
costumes.
Stranger things,
pretty much every 20 something with a
borrowed Netflix password is losing
their mind over season two but why is
everyone so obsessed with a show that's
basically the goonies meet Fox mulder,
some may Pinot on the stall chip,
but I'm going to argue it has a lot to
do with toys,
whether it's kids becoming the rulers of
a nation by engaging in literal warfare
or an animated baby in a suit doing
espionage,
TV and movies about powerful children
tend to age them up in order to
demonstrate their abilities rather than
taking seriously.
The potential of childhood.
Childhood is either something to be
overcome or just comic juxtaposition
against their adult roles.
What makes stranger things unique is
that the kids win by being kit rather
than by growing up or pretending to be
adults.
By paying attention to the way stranger
things in Birch that convention and
shows the inherent power of children,
we can perhaps better understand why the
series resonates so much for
millennials.
Being a kid at heart doesn't mean you're
regressing.
Sometimes it means being a total bad
ass.
Welcome.
This wisecrack addition on stranger
things and as always spoilers ahead if
you need to get caught up.
Here's a quick rundown on the first
season,
a decade before the start of the show,
a secret government funded experiment
kidnaps a girl names her 11 and it makes
her use her psychic powers to spy on the
Soviets and whoops,
summon a demon hell beast from another
dimension.
This piece of tax,
a boy named will and brings him back to,
it's really depressing home dimension,
which is just like earth except the
atmosphere is full of Kleenex pieces and
everything is kind of dam wills.
Three best friends,
Dustin Lucas and Mike set out on a quest
to find him once 11 escapes or creepy
fake dad.
She joins the junior rescue crew and the
rest as they say is eight hours of
quality television,
80s and 90s kid nostalgia certainly
helped give rise to the popularity of
the show,
but that nostalgia extends far beyond
the reach of Netflix.
We also see a certain longing for the
past in the current millennial obsession
with toys witnessed the insane
popularity of Funko pop figurines,
hoverboards and subscription boxes
filled with everything from star wars
pillows to Batman themed ramen bowls,
toys as a symbol express
lightheartedness and innocence,
but they're also an important means for
rational and emotional connection.
Toddlers learn about the world through
their toys.
Children use toys to share or fight with
friends and to act out the possibilities
of the future.
Despite this many popular depictions of
toys trivialize their role,
labeled them as immature and their
popularity has given rise to dozens of
really think pieces on how millennials
need to grow up.
Stranger things takes toys seriously.
They're not only an essential part of
the storyline there,
the foundation on which the rest of the
story is built.
The quintessential example of this is
the way that the language of dungeons
and dragons is used to make sense of
events both for our plucky gang of four
and for the viewers themselves.
We were thinking of more of an able to
mention like do they look shadows when
we first meet the boys in episode one
there in Mike's basement playing d and,
d,
The demo gorgon monster is first shown
is a figurine in their campaign and so
when they meet the interdimensional
monster later on,
they talk about it in terms of a monster
they are familiar with.
This is one of my,
the demagoguery with your wrist rocket.
I took art to do to go into fight darth
vader.
The same is true of the alternate
dimension.
The Monster hails from as 11 tries to
explain what this place is.
Nobody understands until she takes the
campaign board and flips it upside down
to represent an alternate and parallel
side to our own reality.
Since those concepts are fundamental to
making sense of the paranormal element
in the boys' lives there also
fundamental to the viewer.
We really have no way to understand or
express the upside down or the Demo
Gordon,
except through the language of d and d.
That board and that figurine shaped the
mythology for the entire series.
We see the same kind of language framing
in Dustin's constant references to comic
books and Star Wars.
Do you think 11 was born with her powers
like the x men or do you think he
acquired them like like Greenland here
to ham?
11 is one of the x men and the chief is
Lando Kalryzian.
When the boys think he's setting them
up,
what were the chief set us up,
Nancy,
maybe Lado Corinthian.
Would you shut up about Lando?
Dustin knows that Jean Grey has
telekinesis,
so 11 similar powers don't seem
impossible.
His relationship to games and toys and
cartoons gives him and the other
children the ability to understand.
It's powerful.
What does,
this is Hawkins.
This is the robos.
In contrast.
Joy sees evidence of the paranormal and
it pretty much destroys her because she
has no way to communicate this knowledge
to the other adults or even herself
is after him.
He said danger.
We have to find,
everyone thinks she's cuckoo for cocoa
puffs because they simply don't have the
right frame of reference to make sense
of the events except for Mr.
Clark.
His connection to childhood toys and
Games makes him an understanding ally
who entertains the idea of an upside
down well before the other adults.
You know,
that'll shadows echo of the material
plane where necrotic and shadow magic.
Exactly the significance of toys goes
beyond just making sense of the Eggo.
Snuffing demi goddess in the basement on
one level,
stranger things gives credibility to
toys by showing that they have the
potential to be powerful.
When Lucas suggest bringing his wrist
rocket on their adventures,
even his friends make fun of him.
You're going to take out the demo Gorgon
with a slingshot,
and it's true that in the end,
the wrist rocket gets literally beaten
to the Punch by 11 psychic attack on the
demo.
Gorgon.
This may seem like it detracts from our
argument,
but the mere fact that the wrist rocket
was part of the fight shows that it
can't be easily dismissed successfully
or not.
That slingshot,
that toy fought a monster from another
dimension in the world of stranger
things,
toys become objects of great utility.
Nancy's costume chest provides 11 the
ability to move around comfortably in
public.
She can go to school,
meet adults,
and navigate the world more easily after
she plays dress up without the new found
confidence provided by the dress and the
blonde wig.
11 wouldn't have found will on the heat
hit radio or saved Mike from the class
bullies.
She has super powers,
but a dress up bin did something that
esp couldn't.
We can also see the utility of toys and
will's homeaway from home castle buyers.
It's a kid's fort built in the backyard,
but it probably saves his life when he's
in the upside down.
Not only does it shelter him from the
Demo Gorgon,
at least for a little while.
It's also somewhat implied that the
sense of familiarity and comfort
provided by the Fort helps to keep him
alive in the toxic atmosphere.
Perhaps one of the most obvious examples
is the scene where Joyce and 11 pulled
together a makeshift sensory deprivation
tank so that our girl Elle can go
dimension hopping.
They go to a school and Philip,
a Kiddie pool that was once used to bob
for apples.
This scenario despite the participation
of the adults is so laden with kid
fueled ingenuity that it's almost over
the top,
but it's that kitty pool that makes it
possible for 11 to discover barbs body.
Sometimes the role of toys in the show,
it's a little less blatant.
You might've forgotten the scenes were
11 practices,
her powers on the Millennium Falcon
figurine or when we'll get an Atari for
Christmas at the end of the first
season,
definitely an Atari and Atari by making
toys.
A constant presence in the show.
Stranger things emphasizes their
omnipresence and importance in the lives
of children.
The significance of toys isn't always
limited to the kids either.
There are also a few occasions where
toys are important tools for teens and
adults.
Joyce's alphabet light display looks an
awful lot like a wiki board.
Nancy and Jonathan basically recreate
home alone to catch a monster and top it
off with a smiley face.
Yoyo.
Jonathan's very fancy camera is referred
to as his toy was have to take away his
toy.
Please got the camera and it's key to
documenting the existence of the demic
organ by first producing another toy,
a puzzle.
These examples all point to the same
idea.
The Times when the teens and adults are
most successful at fighting the enemy or
understanding the world are when they
adopt the conventions of kids.
This isn't just children having power.
It's the power of childhood itself.
We can see an interesting presentation
of this idea.
In the case of the walkie talkies and
the campuses used in the show,
radios and campuses are not inherently
toys.
They're primarily used for adults for
distinctly uncoil like purposes,
but in stranger things.
They are toys used by the boys as a form
of play prior to taking on their
strategic roles.
The walkie talkies are vital for
communication during the search for will
and the magnetic misdirection of the
campuses leads the gang to the
conclusion that the portal is inside the
Department of Energy Facility,
but we don't see the adults using them
to similar effect.
The police have radios,
but they never hold the same kind of
power or usefulness as the toy radios
belonging to the kids.
So stranger things takes toys seriously
because it takes childhood itself
seriously.
The kids don't save the day despite
being kids.
They save the day because they were
kids.
This doesn't mean that everyone loving
the show wishes they were actually 10
years.
Again,
I wouldn't deal with troy and his elk
for all the fun dips in the world,
but stranger things fights back against
the idea that being a kid or liking toys
is some sort of deficiency.
There isn't just nostalgia in
remembering childhood.
There's power to,
so what does it mean to give toys?
This kind of influence by empowering
childhood is stranger things.
Fanning the flames of our nostalgia
driven culture.
Is it fighting against that by making
childhood into something more than an
ironic tee shirt?
Either way,
we're happy to keep watching season two
pass the eggos and thanks for watching
guys.
He sat and for dinner you'll probably
want something a little more
substantial,
but don't worry.
Blue aprons got you covered.
Seriously guys,
blue apron is offering $30 off to the
first hundred and 50 wives.
Crack fans who sign up from this video.
Be sure you do it with the link at the
end of this video or in the description
below,
blue apron delivers ingredients that
look and taste amazing.
And while I may still only have the
cooking skills of a college freshmen,
our team had no problem following the
easy directions with all the pre
measured ingredients to cook a delicious
meal.
We made pizza with our wine bottle
rolling pin and Mama Mia.
And this month blue apron has more
delicious meals on tap,
including seared steaks and mashed
potatoes and soy marinaded chicken
tenders if you love food.
And One a simple way to cook great meals
at home.
Check out blue apron,
they deliver farm fresh ingredients with
delicious recipes all in a refrigerated
box.
So ingredients stay fresh even if you're
not home when they arrive.
And you can skip or cancel service at
any time.
So if you're looking to expand your
cooking repertoire and hate going to the
grocery store as much as I do,
or just love the idea of fresh
ingredients delivered to your door,
click here to check out blue apron or at
the link in the description below.
And remember the first hundred 50 wise
crack fans to sign up,
get $30 off their first purchase.
Thanks to blue apron for sponsoring this
video.
And I'm getting pretty hungry guys,
so I'm going to peace out,
catch all next time.